schon 111 tage wird gekämpft in der
ukraine kein frieden kein
waffenstillstand in sicht jetzt ist der
donbass wieder das haupt schlachtfeld
die russen gewinnen terrain ukraines
präsident selensky fordert deshalb
weiterhin mehr waffen aus dem westen um
überhaupt eine chance gegen putin zu
haben deutschland liefere weiterhin zu
zögerlich so seine kritik die er
wahrscheinlich morgen direkt an olaf
scholz richten kann denn nach allen
gerüchten werden gemeinsam mit den
staatschefs aus frankreich und italien
wird der bundeskanzler nach kiew reisen
und was werden die europäer dann im
gepäck haben kampf um den don was was
hilft der ukraine unser thema heute in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen bei uns ist ja zum
lenny er ist gebürtiger russe war aber
bis vor einem jahr leiter der heinrich
böll stiftung in kiew wird hat er sechs
jahre gearbeitet ich begrüße professor
klaus segbers er war bis 2019 inhaber
des lehrstuhls für osteuropa studien und
professor für internationale beziehungen
an der freien universität berlin und
direktor des zentrums für global
politics und herzlich willkommen marina
kombi sie ist politische reporterin
weise teilnehmer mit dem schwerpunkt
außen und europapolitik so geschaltet
ist uns professor sind kneissl er ist
historiker mit dem schwerpunkt
militärgeschichte an der universität
potsdam und militärisch wollen wir
erstmal beginnen herr neitzel nach
diesen langen tagen die gekämpft wird
hat man ja das gefühl dass ich im moment
die lage wieder verändert wie würden sie
sagen ja wie ist die militärische lage
geben sie uns ihre einschätzung
es ist zunächst müssen wir sagen das
hier außenstehende das ja hier können
sich die karte interpretieren aber die
wirklich zuverlässige informationen sind
spärlich weil der ukrainische
generalstab allem was ich weiß auch der
bundes wären auch der nato sehr
zögerlich gegenüber es mehr zu sagen als
er ohnehin kultur die amerikaner wissen
sicherlich bilateral mehr die briten auf
aber unsere informationen sind begrenzt
was wir sehen und was wir doch sagen
können ist dass der abnutzung schlacht
im donbass möglicherweise zuerst
entscheidenden punkt ukraine hatten sich
ja nicht entschieden zurück zu ziehen
ihre truppen sagen kampf weg zu halten
sondern sie haben diese schlacht
angenommen und sie allein sehr hohe
verlust was wir sehen ist dass sie in
diesem abnutzungskampf auf dauer den
russen unterlegen sind weil die russen
eine gerade im bereich der artillerie
überlegen sind und die große frage
ist was passiert eigentlich mit der
ukrainischen armee da gerade verliert
sich ihre besten truppen so scheint es
mir und wird in der lage sein das zu
ersetzen und was wir auch sehen ist das
ganze thema und schwere waffen haben wir
ja wissen alle zeitzeugen intensiv
diskutiert was ohne schwere waffen aus
den besten ohne viel mehr hillary die
ukraine eigentlich mittel und
langfristig keine chance hat diese
gebiete zu halten geschweige denn dass
es geht man sagt uns gar nicht sie
zurückzuerobern das ist meines erachtens
eine illusion zumindest nach dem stand
jetzt das heißt aber die schweren waffen
müssen ganz schnell dorthin geliefert
werden ist das realistisch
na ja also wir wissen natürlich auch
nicht alle was die amerikaner die briten
genau tun wir kriegen dann wenn waffen
geliefert worden sind jetzt die norweger
die auch geschützte geliefert haben und
die offenbar schon im einsatz sind
panzerhaubitzen wir kriegen nämlich
nicht alles mit aber in der tat ist es
so die ukraine braucht westlicher
artillerie warum und ihre eigene
artillerie da geht die munition aus die
bulgaren haben noch mal 9000 tonnen
geliefert aber diese alte munition ist
dann irgendwann aufgebraucht und es
nutzen keine geschützte ohne munition
ist jetzt eine gewogene nach allem was
wir wissen wir schauen jetzt natürlich
auch nicht
hinter dem vorhang aber dass ich auch
meine sagt die berechtigte kritik dass
auch deutschland schneller mehr hätte
tun müssen es geht nicht darum dass die
ukraine jetzt die creme erobert oder so
wir haben meines erachtens ein eminentes
interesse dass die ukraine weiter
kämpfen kann dass sie nicht zusammen
zusammenbricht dass diese armee nicht
zusammenbricht und das würde ich nicht
also das ist jetzt auch hunt steht nicht
unmittelbar bevor aber es kann gut sein
dass wir dieser schlacht die ukraine
ganz substanzielle verluste erleidet
denn wir müssen wissen die besten
trocken waren immer auch während der
schlachtung hier im dom boss
das große verlust seit einen haben wir
probleme
ihrer einschätzung nach sehr natürlich
weil sie lange dargelegt haben gute
kontakte auch in die ukraine kann die
ukraine diesen krieg noch gewinnen und
ist die moral der bevölkerung auch so
dass man sagt ja wir kämpfen auf jeden
fall weiter da die ukraine kann diesen
krieg natürlich gewinnen also wir haben
schon gesehen also die kämpfen schon
seit 111 tagen wieder die russen noch
die nato-länder glaubten dass die
ukraine drei tage halten können wir
erinnern uns alle an die stimmung in der
bundesregierung und sagte ja so ein fall
müssen akzeptieren ihrem schicksal das
ist nicht so dass die ukraine kämpfen
seit über drei monaten mit der stärksten
armee was wir glaubten in europa und
jetzt sagen die ukraine ganz okay gut
die russen sind jetzt die zweitstärkste
aber in der ukraine hat von anfang an
die ukraine unterstützt weil sie jetzt
sagen die bundesregierung hätte die
ukraine sozusagen quasi aufgeteilt aber
glaubte nicht dass die ukraine stand weg
sind und dass die ukraine so erfolgreich
den widerstand leisten können dass die
ukraine zum beispiel die russen von
zenit und kiefer rechts vertreiben in
köln also wenn sie sich daran erinnern
können also damals standen sie
russischen truppen schon am start und
kies und jetzt sprechen wir darüber ob
die russin silwia netz geworden also
auch die pläne von russen sind stark
zusammengeschrumpft jetzt zu ihrer frage
ob die ukraine das machen können oder
nicht oder sie wollen oder nicht sie
wollen es machen laut allen umfragen
glauben über 90 prozent der ukrainerin
ukraine an den sieg und noch mehr
glaubende sie kostet wie es wolle
kämpfen müssen warum weil sie wissen
dass es kein kompromiss mit booten
möglich ist sie wissen dass wien die
linke jetzt eine feuerpause anlegen oder
was zum beispiel putin jetzt vorschlägt
dass es war er vorher vorher stillstand
an aus gekündigt angekündigt sein wird
dann werden die millionen von ukraine so
zwei millionen ungefähr welche in den
besetzten gebieten lieben dem russischen
terror weiter exponierter während die
frauen weiter vergewaltigt dann wären
die leute wollten sie kopiert gekidnappt
dann werden die kinder nach russland
geschleppten werden mit ukrainischer
getreide weiter geklaut und so weiter
und so fort das befestigt die russischen
position in den besitz einer behandlung
wären gar nicht möglich ihre meinung die
verhandlungen sind natürlich möglich
aber der einzel das einzige ziel der
verhandlungen sein soll die russen
ziehen sich sofort zurück verlassen das
territorium der ukraine
und ganz ihren der ukraine wirksam die
sicherheit das heißt ein
entmilitarisierter gute sagen wieso 200
kilometer in das russische territorium
auslieferung von kriegsverbrechern nach
dem hart und so wir haben sie müssen das
akzeptieren
wahrscheinlich nicht
das ist ein riesen dilemma indem man ja
nach wie vor von anfang an drin steckt
also gibt es eine möglichkeit weil man
das hörte man jetzt auch von frankreichs
präsidenten der seit mit wir müssen
versuchen da wieder zu verhandeln würden
sie sagen die ukraine kann diesen krieg
gewinnen wenn 90 prozent der bevölkerung
doch noch so dahinter stehen ast hängt
wesentlich davon ab was wir darunter
verstehen zu gewinnen ja also ein gewinn
im sinne eines zusammenbruches russland
damit kann man nicht rechnen das wäre
vielleicht auch nicht so sinnvoll aus
unterschiedlichen gründen ein
standhalten auch über längere zeit wenn
es entsprechend fest fläche
unterstützung gibt kann man sich sehr
wohl vorstellen die ukraine haben wir
einen erstaunlichen spirit gezeigt und
zeigen ihnen immer noch das
bewundernswert und anerkennenswert
ansonsten denke ich muss man bedenken
dass alle seiten auch eine
innenpolitische
dimension zu bedienen haben nicht nur
einander sondern auch die jeweiligen
menschen zu hause in dem sci empfängt
den deutschen bundeskanzler der für 12 3
11 vielleicht ist ja nicht begeistert
ihn zu empfangen aber es wäre sehr
schwierig zu argumentieren warum man das
nicht täte
umgekehrte scholz umgekehrter scholz
reis auch wahrscheinlich mit wenig
begeisterung reißt man sagte früher nach
hessen bildet vielleicht ist das ja auch
hier der fall aber herr scholz hat
ebenfalls innenpolitische probleme vor
allem an seiner eigenen
parlamentsfraktion wo viele
sozialdemokraten sehr skeptisch über den
sonderfonds zur ausstattung der
bundeswehr und viele andere dinge auch
und ähnliches ist bei der makro auch der
fall also das ist sehr wichtig denke ich
dass wir nicht nur die dynamik zwischen
den
hauptakteuren oder scheinbar
hauptakteuren im blick haben sondern
auch die jeweiligen in politischen
landschaften die dahinter stellen nach
allen informationen soll es ja mit
frankreichs präsident makro der als
ministerpräsident die reise eine frau
kommen back i was muss scholz oder die
drei europäer was müssen die im gepäck
haben also was sie diesen titel im
gepäck haben sind eine ganze menge
erwartungen erwartungen aus ihren
ländern bestattungen vor allem aber auch
der ukrainischen seite
was selensky dass die ukrainische
regierung fordert nicht erst jetzt seit
lang sind wie sie sagen waffen waffen
waffen schwere waffen herrn einzel herz
geschrieben worauf es jetzt offenbar
ankommt um im donbass stand zu halten
sind
weitreichende artilleriegeschütze das
ist das was auf der militärischen seite
benötigt wird zugleich aber gibt es die
sehr ausgeprägte forderungen die sehr
klar formulierte forderungen von seiten
der ukraine dass sie eine eu
beitrittsperspektive
erhält auch das ist etwas dass scholz
makro draghi neben können wenn sie denn
wollen wie enttäuscht sind die ukraine
herum lenny von der bundesrepublik von
bundeskanzler scholz naja also die
täuschung von deutschland ist ja groß
und in der ukraine gibt es jetzt auch
ein neues werk so stolzen also etwas zu
versprechen ohne etwas machen zu wollen
oder zu können und dann muss man das
auch in der perspektive sehen die
ukraine hat in neunziger jahre ihre
atomwaffen gegeben abgegeben im
austausch für die sicherheit garantieren
auch seitens russlands in deutschland
war damals nicht dabei aber der westen
insgesamt also die usa und die briten
dann jahrelang haben die ukraine ein
entwaffnung programm gefolgt also was
auch die amerikaner ihnen angezogen
haben damals über
marschflugkörper die selben masche
körper mit denen russland jetzt
ukrainischen städte beschießt
wurden von der ukraine entgegen entweder
vernichtet und auch sich der amerikaner
oder an russland übergeben dasselbe
passierte mit glaube ich 20 aber
mindestens mindestens über ein dutzend
langstrecke strategischen bomber also
die ukraine hat ihre strategische
angriffs kräfte mit den die ukraine
jetzt wenn sie es gewollt hätten die
russischen hauptstadt moskau und die
anderen steht unter beschuss nehmen
könnte militärisch gesehen haben dass
alles entweder vernichtet oder an
russland zurückgegeben die ukraine stand
praktisch blatt und nackt vor diesem
angriff und jetzt wegen die ukraine
angegriffen wird hilft der westen nur
bis zum bis zum bruch dass die ukraine
nicht kollabiert aber nicht die oberhand
gewinnen kann das empfindet und viele
ukraine als eine freiheit und hier
müssen wir sagen dass wir auch für tiere
frechheit also eine frechheit
dass es die gravierenden folgen für die
weltpolitik haben wird war das noch ganz
kurz wird gerne darauf reagieren auf
einer zeit würden sie es auch so negativ
sehen also dass deutschland liefert ja
die amerikaner liefern waffen die briten
liefern waffen also ist wenn man so
sieht was der westen tod ist dass so
wenig
also ich kann die ukrainische position
sehr gut verstehen woran man immer dazu
sagen muss die ukraine hätten mit den
atom noch nichts anfangen können weil
die abschlussquote waren in moskau und
nicht in kiew also man hat ihn letztlich
eine riesige würde abgenommen aber
natürlich ist die lage wie beschrieben
so gewesen dass die ukraine militärische
schwach war sehr schwach war die folge
ist dann auch 2014 ich meine dass ich es
richtig mehr mehr mehr erwünscht ist ist
seine völlig klar und ich würde auch
sagen
also wir schauen nicht nicht im detail
ein die deutschen machen auch mehr als
bekannt ist gerade im nachrichtendienst
bereich aber die entscheidende frage ist
ja aus deutscher sicht gesprochen aus
sicht des westens der europäer vor allem
was wollen wir und wenn wir wollen das
mindestmaß ist ja dass es den
ukrainischen staat weiter gibt wenn das
die ukraine stand halten kann so dass
des ministers und dazu braucht die
ukraine mehr wach also das ist für mich
aber ich
will man dass die ukraine besteht mit
der krim mit dem don was herr 6 4 klar
muss man da haben sie den eindruck dass
man dass das klar ist wohin man
eigentlich will
oder will man die will man die ukraine
davon überzeugen doch
dass russland weiter auf der krim bleibt
das don dass der don was abgegeben wird
in deutschland vielleicht weniger
in den usa relativ aktiv
wir erinnern wahrscheinlich die räte von
kissing job der wurst forum wie viel
aufsehen errichtet weil er da schon
quasi die grundzüge einer möglichen
einigung
versucht so skizzieren ich finde das ist
absolut nicht unsere aufgabe schon gar
nicht die deutsche aufgabe nach 38 und
nach anderen ergebnissen die wir hatten
das also quasi großmächte über die köpfe
von betroffenen versuchen zur einigung
zu kommen das ist ein völlig unmögliches
verhalten also das sollten wir auf
keinen fall tun
ich denke auf mittlere sicht käme es
darauf an das ist schon jetzt von allen
gesagt worden
die ukraine zumindest in die lage zu
versetzen
militärisch nach einer welle
standzuhalten
das wird schwierig genug sein ich
erinner noch mal daran dass auch der
deutsche bundestag zwar das
sondervermögen beschlossen nationen acht
neue ausstattung der bundeswehr aber
jetzt noch sehr zögerlich ist und es
viele diskussionen darüber gibt was
heißt ja die wollen dass hier aus
starten ist das vielleicht auch
entwicklungshelfer oder sind dass
irgendwelche
friedens cams oder was weiß ich was also
dafür ist da ist noch eine menge zu tun
mit anderen worten das geht immer nicht
nicht nur immer um die dynamik zwischen
diesen großen und diplomaten oder
zwischen staaten oder willst du auch
immer es ist auch eine innenpolitische
version wo wir ein problem haben und
einsatz würde ich gern noch hinzufügen
das problem ist auch nach wie vor in
russland problem es gibt nach wie vor in
deutschland menschengedenken wir haben
eine vorübergehende störung zu erwarten
und früher oder später wird sich das
alles wieder sortieren können wir das
ist schön cosi seien freundlich wie man
das früher auch war ja das halte ich für
eine schwere enttäuschung und ich hielte
es für einen massiven fehler aber das
ist vielleicht weiß wo wir doch mal
später darauf zurückkommen kann man
irgendwann merkt es ja wie schwer wir
uns auch wirklich mission hier tun
tatsächlich das ziel diese
auseinandersetzung zu definieren
gewinnen sie haben gesagt die ukraine
kann gewinnen was ist dieser vierte
werden welches in der deutschen politik
dass in das man sich so schwer tut
diesen satz zu sagen die ukraine soll
gewinnen also manche politiker und sich
damit zum beispiel der schau ist der
kanzler genauso schwer die
verteidigungsministerin tut sich schwer
damit sie begründen ist damit dass sie
die ukraine nicht bevormunden wollen
dass sie in dem sie sagen die ukraine
müsse gewinnend quasi eine definition
mitliefern worin denn ein solcher musik
bestehen würde
ich glaube es ist einfach wahnsinnig
schwer den weiteren verlauf dieses
krieges vorauszusehen auch daraus speist
ich glaube ich unser aller ungewissheit
und
desto trotz ist die analyse ja sehr
richtig und wie sie es immer wert haben
dass es weitere waffenlieferungen geben
muss um letztlich den verhandlungsstand
der ukraine in verhandlungen geben dann
irgendwann geben wird zu stärken ja das
wäre nämlich auch die frage also wenn
man immer sagt die ukraine muss das
entscheiden aber sie kann es würde ja
gerne in der eu sie würde ja gerne mehr
unterstützung aus dem westen also sie
ist doch abhängig vom fest die ukraine
hat schon entschieden also 90 prozent
über 90 prozent der ukrainerin stehende
führte sie den kampf fortsetzen wollen
und gewinnen möchten und die eu und nato
beiträgt dass stehen die beiden in der
ukrainischen verfassung also wir haben
schon entschieden also ich möchte noch
mal sagen also die ukraine hat sich
entwaffnet die ukraine hat einen enormen
beitrag für die welt sicherheits
getragen aber erstmal nichts genutzt und
die haben genau und zu der eskalation
und jetzt müssen wir als die
internationale gemeinschaft die ukraine
ein land welches für diese entspannung
330 jahre lang bei druck müssen wir
helfen stellen sie vor was für ein bild
liefern wir jetzt den anderen ländern
wir zeigen ihnen zuerst dass ein nuklear
bestücktes macht bestimmtes land die
anderen städte platt machen kann als die
millionenstädte wie hp wurde die 600.000
städte wie marie opel die dürfen die
bevölkerung deportieren die dürfen also
alle mögliche kriegsverbrechen verüben
unbestraft und das land welches
angegriffen wird bekommt nur so wenig
unterstützung vom westen und von der
größten militärischen allianz wird
menschheit von der nato dass sie nur
vielleicht nicht kollidieren wird das
ist ja die länder haben jetzt hat er
auch noch mal gesagt sie würden mehr
waffen liefern ich hoffe dass er so
passiert nur was wir bis zu bis zum zwei
tagen 111 tage
leisten die ukrainerinnen widerstand und
die werden nur sehr begrenzt geholfen
das ist ein super schlechte beispiel den
wir an die welt liefern weil jetzt alle
länder die diktatorischen länder werden
darüber denken sie müssen atom bewaffnet
werden weil sie und alles machen können
dann kann man jetzt kann man viel ist
viel sagen was nicht gut gelaufen ist
dass wir zu spät liefern zu wenig
liefern jetzt sagt die bundesregierung
sie liefert noch drei raketenwerfer also
muss man sagen es ist sowieso jetzt
alles zu spät das kind das sozusagen in
den brunnen gefallen wir oder gibt es
eine möglichkeit wo sie sagen doch da
gibt es militärisch jetzt noch eine
möglichkeit so viel so schnell dorthin
zu bekommen dass es wirklich eine chance
gibt die russen militärisch zu schlagen
also ich halte die vorstellung dass die
ukraine
die russen von ihrem territorium vertrag
für eine illusion für eine militärische
illusion denn der wille ist sicherlich
da würde ich dem gesagten darunter
zustimmen aber wenn man auf die genauen
möglichkeiten der ukrainischen
streitkräfte schaut ist das schlicht
meines erachtens schlicht nicht möglich
das ist eine meinung die von vielen
militärischen experten dazu geteilt wird
wenn der erst wenn das so ist dann
müsste sagen muss ist dann die
konsequenz keine waffen liefern
weil weil konsequenz von keiner
waffenlieferungen wäre dass die ukraine
ist den krieg verliert gegen russland
und da ist glaube ich auch der
politische wille da das darf nicht
passieren und ich glaube wir sollten mit
dem begriff gewinnen wäre ich sehr
vorsichtig setzt wende es wurde erwähnt
was ist das eigentlich aber gewinnen
wäre mindestens die russischen soldaten
von dem territorium zu verteidigen und
zu mindestens status quo ante 24 februar
das würde ich aus militärischen gründen
könnte ich näher ausführen von einer
illusion halten zumindest jetzt am 15
juni aber es ist möglich und das ist
glaube ich unser aller forderung hier in
dieser runde dass der westen auf
deutschland mindestens ebenso
wichtigen muss sich die front halten
kann und da das ist schon möglich macht
uns nur wer wird sich auf deutschland
kommen sie haben die drei raketenwerfer
erwähnt
und soweit ich das weiß liegt im
verteidigungsministerium immer noch
nicht ein klarer auftrag vor diese
raketen werfer einsatzbereit zu machen
und ausbildungsprogramme zu launchen da
hat ist das kanzleramt nicht tätig
geworden und diese raketenwerfer sind in
einem schlechten zustand also kannst du
scholz verspricht der dinge
da ist eine große chance dahinter und
letztlich hängt man das müssen wir uns
in klammer es hängt von den gruß an das
schicksal der ukraine hängt von den usa
ganz sicher nicht von deutschland und da
werde ich jetzt sein emotionales meines
erachtens ein armutszeugnis der 450
millionen europäer dass sie in diesem
krieg die sicherheit und sagen die
geschwindigkeit letztlich an die usa
wieder ausgelagert das ist dasselbe
problem aus der in syrien und anderen
konflikten gesehen haben das ist ein
zustand der sich ändern sollte unter
schritt wäre wirklich auch in
deutschland mehr zu tun die ukraine
braucht diese hilfe und ich glaube wir
können sie auch liefern ohne dass es zu
einem atomkrieg um
das würden sie das auch so sehen dass
die europäer immer noch so viel
schwächer sind und das sind dass man
doch immer noch auf die usa hielt damit
die es lösen und tut ihnen vielleicht
auch derjenige verbraucht beiden als
verhandlungsführer und nicht jemand aus
europa
und das stimmt ein stück weit aber die
europäer sind gerade dabei oder haben
die unerwartete chance könnte mannes
zeigen dass zu lernen auf dem harten weg
dass sie selber einfach mehr
verantwortung übernehmen müssen
deutschland muss das tun bezogen auf
seine brennstoffe das billige beziehen
aus russland ist vorbei das muss das tun
bezogen auf seine sicherheit das
freerider tun also mitfahrer effekte
haben die amerikaner werden uns schon
aushalten und sind für sicherheit
zuständig und wir müssen wir schauen was
wir bezahlen ist vorbei
den exporten
alters haben dass man den
exportweltmeister hat man im
wesentlichen wegen der ausfälle corinna
china das ist jedenfalls vorbei ist dass
wir haben drei große dinge wo wir jetzt
wissen wir müssen erwachsen werden ja
sie an gott im nebensatz gesagt ist es
zu spät ich würde sagen nein es ist
nicht zu spät
aus zwei gründen ein grund ist dass
dieser europäische konflikt sicher
anlage in einen globalen konflikt wenn
man einen globalen realität sondern
kampf zwischen liberalen systemen
regelbasierten system auf der einen
seite und autoritären auf der anderen
und da passt diese konzept dieser
aktuelle konflikte nähren dass würden
nicht vorbei nicht schlimm und das
zweite ist dass wir häufig ein bisschen
zu schnell von russland sprechen was ist
das denn also wir haben in russland im
augenblick eine führung schon seit
längerer zeit deren eigene dem ehrenmal
wesentliches glück darin besteht dass
sie sich in der erde öl und gas hatten
ich erkenne sonst wesen wenig an
aufbauleistung wenig an die exportiert
werden können und dass repräsentierte
gegenwärtige führung und das ist für die
gegenwärtige führung auch ein kampf auf
leben oder tod das ist eins der
wahlkampf für die aktuelle führung das
wird uns auch noch eine weile erhalten
bleiben leider insofern ist es nicht zu
spät zumal wir uns schon ganz genau
überlegen was wir jetzt machen während
wir die unterstützte person
denn die haben sie den eindruck dass man
dann dass man vor allen dingen auch an
die eu fordert oder ist es dann doch
wieder etwas wo man dann gerade im
moment sehr stark auf deutschland schaut
naja man schaut natürlich auf
deutschland deutschland ist das größte
eu-land natürlich auch insgesamt an die
eu und müssen es auch verstehen das ist
in unserem interesse dass die ukraine
gewinnt es ist so genau wissen wann man
hat ja ich würde wenn ich würde sagen
mindest aus ist die kontakt linie von
dem 22 24 februar zu erreichen das ist
mindestens ob die ukraine dann sich
aufhalten glaube ich nicht und das ist
ihr gutes recht nach dem internationalen
recht die besetzten gebiete zu befreien
und wir müssen uns nicht verstecken ich
vergessen also da leben auf die
ukrainische staatsbürgerinnen und bürger
welche unter römische herrschaft dort
leben müssen und die russland russland
benutzt sie als kanonenfutter es gibt
keine männer fast mehr in den besetzten
dort aus weil die russen die alle männer
vom alter im alter von 18 bis 50 auf den
straßen praktisch fest nehmen sie mit
gewehren aus dem ersten weltkrieg
bestücken und sie und auch der
frontlinie schicken weil für putin ist
es wichtiger dass die zuerst als erste
welle sterben und dann schickt er seine
eigenen truppen also die ukraine hat
vitales interesse ihre leute zu retten
und das steht ihnen auch nach dem
internationalen recht das ist kein
völkerrecht buch oder sowas und
hier müssen wir den ukrainerinnen
unterbringen helfen mit waffen mit
munition mit raketen mit allen möglichen
dingen und das ist in unserem interesse
warum weil wen sich jetzt so die kontakt
linie so stabilisiert dass alle diese
gebiete was putin jetzt in der hand hat
wenn er alle diese gebiete kontrollieren
kann dann wird er sie einverleiben dann
werden die leute dort benutzt genauso
wie diese wie diese menschen wellen für
den weiteren angriff dann wird die
ukraine von dem meer vom schwarzen meer
fische mehr abgeschnitten dann wird die
ukraine wirtschaftlich erdrosselt dann
müssen wir die ukraine retten das ist
nicht mehr zu retten dann wird putin
auch seine weitere angriffe vorbereiten
er wird vor allem sehen dass er das
machen kann das macht er nach jedem
halbe gewonnenen krieg georgien hat
nicht ganz gewonnen nur halt gewohnt und
dann macht er trotzdem den neuen angriff
in dornbach don was hat ja nicht
gefahren und halb gewonnen und dann
nochmal angriff wen wir jetzt dass die
befürchtung die sie haben dass das dann
hätten weiter oder sie wird uns noch
mehr kosten und dann müssen wir uns
keine illusionen machen wenn wir jetzt
versuchen mit weniger waffenlieferungen
die eine eskalation zu vermeiden wir
machen den gegenteil wir geben wir geben
mehr benzin in diese eskalation und das
bekommen wir im nächsten jahr oder in
zwei jahren egal das werden wir alles
erleben kann wie haben sie den dass es
in der deutschen politik angekommen ist
dass auch das herzig das gesagt hat dass
er so zu erwachsen werden müssen das
wäre eine andere
rolle spielen müssen in der welt da ich
glaube in einer analyse ist man klar das
ist angekommen aber ob man die richtigen
schlüsse daraus zieht ob man die analyse
in die tat umsetzt daran habe ich
sondervermögen hin oder her doch noch
einige zweifel dass besonders bei der
spd fraktion ein problem naja gut der
kanzler hat die richtlinienkompetenz ist
fällt maßgeblich auf ihn zurück und ja
die spd fraktion die spd im allgemein
hängt sicherlich noch ein an
weltbildern die sich spätestens mit dem
24 februar als überholt offenbart haben
es gibt
müssen sie der bundeskanzler die
bundesregierung betont immerzu auch wenn
es um neue waffenlieferungen geht dass
man sich im einklang mit den partnern
mit den alliierten verhält das ist ja
auch richtig und wichtig so was daraus
aber auch spricht ist eine mangelnde
bereitschaft
voranzugehen tatsächlich die europäer
zusammen zu halten sei es beim thema
waffenlieferung oder auch bei diesen
elenden
versuchen irgendwie 1 6 sanktionspaket
zu schnüren auch da hat man gemerkt dass
eine führungsmacht in europa gerade
fehlt tatsächlich und die europäer schon
auf deutsch muss macht oder eine
führungspersönlichkeit
möglicherweise in personalunion die
europäer schauen auf deutschland und
deutschland schaut auf die usa wenn sie
zum beispiel heiß ich glaube eine
debatte die der wir uns vielleicht eher
früher als später werden stellen müssen
die frage nach der lieferung von kampf
und schützenpanzern da heißt es von
deutscher seite die amerikaner machen
sie auch nicht da auch hier geht man
sich dran verdient und dann verstreicht
immer mehr zeit und mit der zeit und mit
der zeit verstreicht möglicherweise auch
die bereitschaft zu helfen wir gewöhnen
uns an den krieg ja es kommt jetzt
irgendwie der sommer
die leute wollen was anderes ja womit
sie sich beschäftigen können als dieser
schrecklichen bilder das hat ja etwas
verständlich ist aber ich glaube das ist
gerade eine ganz kritische phase in der
wir uns tatsächlich befinden weil
die solidarität droht nachzulassen im
politischen aber auch in der in der
bevölkerung
und möglicherweise zu verhöhnen kreative
tonfall lässt sich ja auch ein bisschen
wenn man sagt wir müssen doch wieder
jetzt verhandeln alter die nicht
demütigen karotin nicht mit putin nicht
demütigen ganz genau das sind alles so
alles so zeichen und zum beispiel von
den amerikanern ist gerade zu hören da
gibt es eine gewisse unzufriedenheit
darüber dass die ukraine nicht ihre
ganzen informationen zum fortgang des
kampfes im dom was teilen würden also
auch da ist so eine art misstrauen was
ich gerade breit macht also es ist
vielleicht nehmen uns echt nicht
gepunktet preise wurden die würden sich
einschätzen nähern wir uns da ist das
und kipp punkt ist das jetzt schon so
ein moment wo sich der wurde sich dieser
krieg in einer phase befindet die im
jahr in eine ganz andere richtung geht
als zuvor
das ist immer so die frage an den
historiker jetzt sagen sie doch endlich
wie es weitergeht wissen natürlich nicht
und wir haben es auch schon in der runde
gesagt wir können den verlauf von
kriegen nicht provozieren würde ich von
so vielen faktoren abhängig sind aber
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich an an den
widerstandswillen der ukraine vor allem
was nicht von der ukraine weiß es ist
nicht viel aber ein bisschen schon gibt
es in der bevölkerung ein nach wie vor
einen ungebrochenen widerstandswillen
sie haben einen präsidenten der in den
weg weist und damit zwingen sieht die
europäer zumindest in einem gewissen
umfang hilfe zu leisten ich bin ich
selber einer katastrophe wenn selensky
von einem russischen killerkommando
umgebracht werden würde oder so mit
diesen mitte mit der ukraine so wie ich
das bein entstehen dann wie ein mann
hinter ihrem präsidenten sie kämpfen sie
kämpfen unter hohen opfern und das
zwingt die europäer etwas zu tun ich
glaube eher dass es darauf hinausläuft
dass ja kann man nicht prognostizieren
aber jetzt ist offenbar wenn man die
letzten region von lohans verliert und
dass ich weiß nicht was vielleicht auch
die volksrepublik dorn jetzt verlor geht
und dann glaube ich nicht dass die
russen in dieser intensität jetzt über
weit über den sommer hinaus den kampf
fortsetzen werden und dann das ist dann
wird es eine interessante es war es aber
dann glaube ich mit dem waffenstillstand
regeln landet die frage sein die
europäer weiter bereit sind die ukraine
zu unterstützen und für einige ist die
frage wie weit sind die europäer
eigentlich bereit die ukraine
aufzurüsten was der lenz gelegen ist
jetzt gefordert hat das werden die auch
ob er nicht liefern die amerikaner
glaube ich auch nicht und die frage ist
wo kommen wir da wo kommen wir da hin
und noch mal gesagt ich kann es mir
nicht vorstellen so wünschenswert wäre
so wünschenswert wäre dass
die ukrainer auch von ihrer armee her
aufgrund der verluste in der lage sein
werden diese gebiete zurückzuerobern
dann müsste eigentlich die russische
armee zusammenbrechen und das sehen wir
eben noch nicht das bedeutet das aber
wenn es sehr hohe verluste gibt und das
kann sie als das tor her wahrscheinlich
schon gut einschätzen wie wie ändert
sich dann sozusagen der der kampf willen
in der bevölkerung gibt es da so punkt
wo man das wenn die verluste so hoch
werden dass man an einem punkt ist man
sagt wir müssen dieser kriegen muss
irgendwie beendet werden auch wenn wir
dadurch ja das verlieren was wir nicht
verlieren wollten ich glaube dass die
klima in einer völlig anderen lage sind
wie die deutschen es gibt ja um fragen
wer ist bereit sein land mit der woche
zu verteidigen da ist in europa glaube
ich deutschland hat den niedrigsten wert
was aber auch daran liegt dass
deutschland von freunden umgeben ist und
die russen nicht an den seelower höhen
stehen die ukraine kämpft um ihre
existenz das müssen wir sagen ganz klar
formulieren und sie haben den richtigen
präsidenten und sie sind meines
erachtens auch von diesen schlimm
verlusten die sie schon haben nicht
geschwächt pikant ist also da ist die
ukraine noch lange nicht am ende der
fahnenstange das gesagt aufgrund der
verluste hören sie auf das anderes
anderer punkt ist die armee die ukraine
hat seit 2014 ihrer armee mit hilfe der
usa und großbritanniens ausgebildet
besser ausgerüstet und die besten
verbände der ukrainischen armee standen
immer im dom bass und die erleiden jetzt
sehr hohe verluste und wir sehen jetzt
eben auch dass die milizverbände
längst nicht die kampfkraft haben die
kampffähigkeit haben und noch mal zu
verteilen ist das eine militärisch
gesehen anzugreifen ist
technisch sage ich jetzt mal ein völlig
anderes eine völlig andere sache und da
fehlt mir und vielen anderen der glaube
dass die ukraine dazu in der lage ist
die es ist ja erwähnt worden ist und so
das hat man vor allem deswegen zurück
aber und können wir die kosten sich
zurückgezogen haben nicht nur aber vor
allen dingen auch und ich meine ich ich
würde das der unerwünschten das wäre
wunderbar wenn ich in der lage wäre bis
3 zu kämpfen aber das glaube ich nicht
was geht was genau muss ja was passiert
wenn scholz morgen in die nach kreis
also noch ist das ja immer noch nicht
offiziell bestätigt aber sicherlich auch
aus sicherheitsgründen auch nicht
bestätigt was wäre das wäre das der
beste fall okay ich würde vom
schlimmsten fall anfangen der schlimmste
fall wäre wenn man froh und stolz den
sie lenski dem präsent selensky
frieden diktat mitbringen und versuchen
werden ihn zu irgendwelchen frieden zu
zwingen wir müssen uns verstehen dass
dass der frieden mit russland unter
heutigen zuständen umstellt und heutigen
umständen für die ukraine die deutlich
größeren verluste auch an menschenleben
bedeuten wird als der grausame krieg
jetzt das muss verstanden werden der
frieden mit russland wenn jetzt in den
besetzen gebieten durch die russischen
armee wird den ukrainischen
leuten der bevölkerung mehr mehr mehr
mehr tote bringen und den anderen
frieden wird punkten jetzt nicht mehr
nicht akzeptieren dass weil erstens ein
normales spiel ist ein stück
direktoriums zu kontrollieren und dann
sagen wir machen vorher pause und dann
werde ich irgendwie diese leute dann zum
gehorsam bringen das nur eins was wäre
der gute ball der gute fall wäre wegen
der bundeskanzler scholz und der
präsident mal kommt sagen zum morgen
bekommt ihr die schweren waffen das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren aber
jetzt müssen wir auch uns daran erinnern
erinnern wir uns an putin am 9 mai bei
der siegerparade in moskau ein komplett
zerbrochene alte mann der unter einem
und das unter eine decke sitzt und
niemand mit ihm spricht er war komplett
deprimiert und vor wenigen tagen als er
vor den studierenden saß ganz glücklich
strahlend und über den packenden großen
diskutierte was zwischen diesen zwei
putins passierte in diesen anderthalb
monaten damals am 9 mai gab es die
ankündigung vom westen von
waffenlieferungen und dann kamen die
waffen und dann dachte er wahrscheinlich
jetzt stehe ich kurz vor dem abgrund
weil ich diese ukrainische gegen
offensive im norden im osten nicht
halten kann und jetzt sieht er okay dass
scholz scholz der verspricht nur
überliefert sagt nichts und
darüber mal die haubitzen die jobs sind
kamen nicht also wurden versprochen aber
die kamen nächste woche nächste woche so
weit sein nächste woche gegen ersten der
sieben geliefert werden die ausbildung
endet diese woche alles passiert ja
durchaus sehen als sie liefert sein
werden dann öffne ich eine flasche von
guten wein bisher glaube ich nicht bis
ich sie nicht sie werde mit meinen
eigenen augen aber wichtig ist zwischen
diesen zwei putin lagen anderthalb
monate von verzögerung an
waffenlieferungen und das ist das
schlimmste was passieren kann dass die
waffen auch weiter versorgt werden und
gut wenn sie sofort geliefert werden was
glauben sie was scholz und man kaum
mitbringen und gäbe es gibt es einen
irgendeine möglichkeit wo man sagt da
kriegt man einen waffenstillstand hin
indem man auch auf putin zugeht oder ist
das völlig ausgeschlossen der vertreter
eines landes was seinen letzten 15
jahren unzählige male geltende abkommen
verletzt hat unzählige male dem würde
ich nicht von dienstag bis donnerstag
ehrlich gesagt egal worum es gilt
insofern ist das familienfest es kann
keinen keinen großen durchbruch für
immer geben das andere ist dass selbst
wenn es irgendwie ein waffenstillstand
gebe das gilt vielleicht für anteil der
moerser der granatwerfer uns bereitet
der panzer das gilt aber nicht für
partizan und wir werden mit sicherheit
bei einem waffenstillstand damit rechnen
müssen dass es in beträchtlichem umfang
der ukraine soll ich habe partisan
bewegungen gibt und besser als in kiew
bin ich der meinung könnte der
bundeskanzlerin deutschland versuchen
der menschen hier klar zu machen warum
es wichtig ist die ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen im herzen der leute sie
empfehlen nicht mehr durch wir haben
einen angehenden sich verschärfenden
klimawandel wir brauchen nur tanzen raus
zu gehen hat das thermometer anzuschauen
wir haben eine wieder erstarkende
pandemie meldung von heute wir haben
zerbrechen der
produktions und lieferkette im
zusammenhang mit globalisierung den ich
mir funktionieren werden tausende von
containern in denen helfen stehende
nicht entladen werden
inflation des firma nächster punkt
gewesen dann geschehen kommt auch der
zug und die menschen sehen dann nicht
mehr durch und die regierung oder auch
er müssten in der lage sein ein relativ
anzubieten warum es wichtig ist auch die
ukraine weiter zu unterstützen sondern
teil des negativs muss europa leuten der
2 der zweite mal dann 2004 23 10 14 13
14 begann damit dass der damalige
präsident sich kurzfristig von dem
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu
verabschiedete auf druck von moskau und
die leute standen tagelang auf einmal da
not haben berufen europa europa europa
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
wie offen ist europa der frau kompakt
was glauben sie wie wird es eine chance
geben dass das morgen zu sagen ein
geschenk an herrn sie lernen wo man sagt
ja bitte die kandidatur als
beitrittskandidat wird umgesetzt sind
ganz große frage wir warten auf den
freitag am freitag will die eu
kommission ihre empfehlungen
veröffentlichen ob die ukraine den eu
beitrittskandidaten status erhalten soll
dann werden die eu staats und
regierungschefs auf ihrem gipfel in der
kommenden woche darüber entscheiden
georgi und geht auch mal doch nicht nur
die ukraine das was ich hier in berlin
beobachte ist zunächst einmal eine sehr
große zurückhaltung reserviert 24
gewesen von seiten der bundesregierung
obmann der ukraine eine solche eu
beitrittsperspektive geben sollte über
die letzten wochen hat sich da so ein
bisschen was verändert weder der kannst
dann auch die außenministerin haben bis
dann sich offen dazu bekannt dass sie
den kandidatenstatus für die ukraine
wünschen es wäre eine überraschung wenn
herr scholze bei seinem besuch das
formulieren würde
allerdings wissen wir auch dass makro
dass die franzosen auf europäischer
ebene derzeit viel unternehmen um genau
dies zu verhindern makro skizziert
gerade seine idee einer europäischen
politischen gemeinschaft also einer
neuen runde eines neuen debattierte
jeder irgendwie mitmachen kann ohne dass
es allzu verbindlich ist das ist das was
man die ukraine anbietet also wir sehen
auch hier die europäer sind sich uneins
was wir gehen wenn man das etwas ja
sexualisiert gesagt habe dass etwas was
da alles daran hängt und dann auf dann
doch diese zögerlichkeit es ist einmal
deutlich ganz verstehen es ist in der
tat verwunderlich denn ich denke auch
also meinem einen blick ist auch die
politischen kosten für einen solchen
weitere kandidaten status während für
die europäer wirklich nicht hoch aber
man stelle sich mal vor was passieren
wird nächste woche wenn die eu staats
und regierungschefs der ukraine die tür
vor die nase zuknallen das wäre ein ein
misstrauensvotum für den ukrainischen
präsidenten die kalte schulter eiskalte
schulter gegenüber der ukrainischen
bevölkerung eine ein einbruch innerhalb
der europäer denn auch da gibt es ja
starke fürsprecher für eine eu-weite
trader status vor allem ost- und
mitteleuropa und ein weiterer sieg
folgen putin wie würden sie sehen ja so
ein lemming so gibt es überhaupt eine
möglichkeit also wenn jetzt der
kandidatenstatus nicht wenn dem nicht
zugestimmt wird was heißt das bringe
ja dass wir uns für die ukraine eine
sehr angenehme überraschung sein
oder besser gesagt eine sehr unangenehme
tatsache keine überraschung dar wir
haben schon die äußerungen von einigen
eu regierungschefs ort wieder mark rutte
von den niederlanden und die anderen
welche sehr skeptisch sich gegenüber dem
kandidatenstatus geäußert haben oder den
kandidatenstatus mit befüllung von
gewissen von gewissen anforderungen
geknüpft zusammen geknüpft haben was
schon
eine eine ein widerspruch in sich ist da
normalerweise bekommt man zuerst
kandidatenstatus und gibt es sein
roadmap mit den verpflichtungen und dann
gibt es die
eu-beiträge und für die ukraine wert ist
so in der ukraine werde so wahrgenommen
werden okay die europäer haben uns zum
nächsten mal über den tisch gezogen
aber wir haben dann die echten freunde
in der eu das sind die polen das sind
die balken ersten litauen lenken da sind
die tschechen da sind die slowaken das
in die briten welche gott sei dank aus
der eu weg sind so wird es interpretiert
werden und da wird es diese wunsch nach
der anderen allianz als die eu größe
sein also man nennt es einige nennen es
diese inter mario also diese services
initiativ mit den polen mit den balken
mit den anderen die anderen sagen so
nordeuropa allianz mit den
großbritannien und so weiter da wird das
wird er uns schaden am ende weil die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen so oder so
daran bin ich mir sicher die frage ist
nur mit welchen kosten und wie schnell
aber wenn sie diesen krieg gewinnen
werden sie werden es nicht vergessen wer
ihnen geholfen hat und wer nicht und
glauben sie mir wir haben heute nicht
genug getan um die ukraine zu
verteidigen um den zu hilfe zu helfen da
die werden so ist eindeutig
interpretieren werden und uns das nicht
vergessen wenn polanski in dieser frage
die tür vor der nase zugeschlagen würde
das für ein solcher erfahrungen den kann
er sich nicht leisten
also irgendetwas wird man anbieten
müssen obwohl die sache einer substanz
außerordentlich schwierig ist denn es
gibt auch noch den westbalkan wo gerade
auch reisen stattgefunden haben ist es
sehr schwer und mazedonien noch zu
argumentieren dass sie weiter warten
müssen die ukraine hat in einem fest
reck und zieht vorbei
aber einfach zu sagen nein das gibt es
nicht das wird nicht möglich sein womit
rechnen sie daher ein einzel wie sollte
die eu sich darauf stellen
ich glaube die eu wird auch wir wie
gesagt wurde was anbieten denn die
alternative wäre ja dass es sich
militärisch viel stärker engagiert und
da dem argument ist etwas dran sie
engagieren sich da sieht ruhiger was
aber eben eher zögerlich nicht genug
belasten den amerikanern das feld und da
hat es glaube ich deutschland und auch
andere länder schwerer mehr zu tun und
dann wird man sich glaube ich in dieser
frage bewegen um dann zu sagen wir haben
zumindest diplomaten schlossen
alle zum schluss weil sie haben so viele
persönliche beziehungen nach kiew werden
sie dahin reisen wort ja ab jede zeit
also das ist mein großer traum jetzt
nach kiew reisen zu dürfen
und dass wir das erste sein was ich
immer hinreißend habe sind wir gespannt
sind alles gute in vielen dank frau
kompakt herr professor bereits von
vielen dank für die diskussion vielen
dank fürs zuschauen die phoenix runde
heute morgen schauen wir natürlich noch
mal auf die ukraine denn wenn es so
stimmt wie alle informationen sagen und
bundeskanzler schon scholz morgen nach
kiew reist wollen wir natürlich am abend
in der phoenix runde darüber sprechen
was aus dieser reise dann geworden ist
bis dann
[Musik]